this guy reality addict Chad Johnson he
is crashed and burned in the bachelor
franchise and now he is back on a new
show famously single we just can't quit
you're chad ET on lines lauren zima has
more in a couple words who is the Chad
people don't know what are some
characteristics Oh perfect emotional
sensitive I mean day in day out I just
got to wake up and remind myself it's
okay to be perfect okay Chad because the
last time we saw the Bachelorette
villain on a reality TV show it was far
from a picture of perfection come at me
serious men in less than 24 hours he was
booted from bachelor in paradise after
drinking too much and making threats now
he's looking for love and a second
chance on famously single we went
straight from attraction until are we in
love it does show a different side of me
but I just gonna show up and be myself
how do you compare the partying on
Paradise to the partying on this show I
mean there is some partying but it's uh
there's no like extreme craziness and
the cast doesn't attack anyone like on
refreshing paradise guys yeah I don't
have to like defend myself like a
cornered beast there's still a decent
side Chad I mean I'm still super super
muscular what are your tips for dating
ladies want to get the perfect guy like
me take care of yourself
think positive and try and be successful
in your own right because you know
successful guys don't really want to
find someone who's just like a leak have
you ever regretted not asking somebody
out on a date anybody who you'd wish
you'd made that move and you didn't I
regret every time I see a hot girl I
don't ask her out on a date I saw like
10:00 on the way here I'm really pissed
off at myself away I have a girlfriend
so there is a woman out there who will
put up with his shenanigans um
apparently model Zoe Baron is his
girlfriend believe it or not I mean he's
just so attractive isn't too
[Music]